c'est le capitaine adam la capitale
d'une danemark lui donne mark lamia
maroc
non mais l'ol a bien fait s'entraîner au
lac de la suisse bah si ce nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ton âge ta pas contre d'histoire
instant si ta place à l'est du cap
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un ici ou là fou
quoi vous êtes déjà filmé avec qui avec
mon compagnon avec lui sur la tête de
maman j'espère que son père et regarde
pas imagine ou pas ce soir louis je peux
toujours deux minutes
est ce que c'est que cette histoire du
sex tape et paris je termine pas pas
dans ma peau et à filmer
non mais franchement non mais attendez à
supprimer après quoi vous supprimez pas
on regarde on sait mais les gars comme
et vous faites des dits multi film bat
nous menons une équipe de tournée elle
vous attrape rousset capucines ou à
écouter le m'appelle de buteur faites
vous un petit bisou
[Applaudissements]
vous devez voir vraiment où le ratio
n'est jamais de la vie en mai
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'amour
c'est pas possible ça ne tient pas
debout les yeux quand j'arrive à tout
nettement aussi bas je veux dire
regardez cette des tartans
on écrit une indique la ronaldo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien là
ce qui s'est passé là au ski mais voilà
assez harassante tous ensemble c'est
très très bien entendu et je suis désolé
de révéler sa mais oui chacun est rentré
dans ses pénates
ouais et au bout d'un moment j'entends
un petit grattements à la porte je me
dis mais qui vient m'embêter à 1h du mat
et c'était la capuche et à capuche elle
aurait bien aimé avant hier un petit
bisou à aumale god et non pas d'appui à
béziers non mais c'est non en me disant
et nos envies de toi prêt mais pourquoi
il semble finalement on va serait pas un
petit moment un petit peu fort
[Musique]
j'avais déjà lu et votre culotte à
l'école où elle était dans mon pantalon
elle était jeune je faisais une poésie
et ma culotte était descendu dans mon
jean ballard est très souvent capitale
des états unis new york non
alors allez tout boston voilà la
capitale des états unis boston
[Musique]